disgraced r b Superstar that's R Kelly
who is waking up a convicted felon this
morning for crimes going back decades a
New York jury found R Kelly guilty on
all charges yesterday including sex
trafficking and racketeering he faces
additional charges in two other states
and he could face life in prison R
Kelly's conviction has been met with
relief from his victims who suffered for
years while he thrived as a recording
artist with 12 platinum records and sold
out shows he continued to deny the
allegations most notoriously while
speaking to Gail of course back in 2019
that followed the release of a
documentary called surviving R Kelly
When many of his victims spoke publicly
for the very first time arjurika Duncan
has been following this story since 2018
and she joins us again this morning
darika good to see you again good
morning to you back then we interviewed
a woman who said R Kelly knowingly gave
her an STD when she was 19 and he was
50. now that allegation was included in
this federal case along with many more
dating back to the early 90s after court
our Kelly's attorney said the r b Mogul
was not anticipating a guilty verdict
today's guilty verdict forever Brands R
Kelly as a predator
who used his Fame and Fortune to pray on
the young the vulnerable and the
voiceless for his own sexual
gratification after roughly nine hours
of deliberation over two days a jury
found R Kelly guilty of all nine counts
the decision came after hearing from 50
Witnesses including 11 accusers six of
whom said they were underage when Kelly
sexually abused them at times the
testimony was Vivid and graphic one
witness told the court she saw Kelly in
a sex act with the lead singer Aaliyah
when she was around 13. attorney Gloria
Allred represents several Kelly accusers
his control over those victims is long
gone
he underestimated them and they told
their truth and as a result Mr Kelly is
no longer a sexual predator on the loose
prosecutors accuse Kelly of using his
high profile status to control and
sexually abuse his victims throughout
the proceedings Kelly remained largely
stoic never taking the standings
evidence why should he anticipate this
verdict Kelly's attorneys tried to
dispel the prosecution's claim that
Kelly ran a criminal Enterprise in a
statement they said the Enterprise was
based on a series of independent
relationships and events the government
patched together like different types of
fabrics and passed it off as silk the
54-year-old Grammy winner has long
denied allegations of sexual misconduct
with underage girls have you ever had
sex with anyone under the age of 17.
never no in a 2019 interview with Gail
King he doubled down I didn't do this
stuff this is not me I'm fighting for my
life it's something that you just don't
get over Kelly accuser Lizette Martinez
known as Jane Doe number nine says she
was 17 when Kelly first sexually abused
her it's just a really great feeling to
finally feel like we matter we were
heard
and you know we can start to heal and
start going on with our lives
Kelly's attorneys say they are sure that
they will appeal this verdict Kelly's
legal troubles don't end with this case
he still faces a federal trial in
Chicago and he has pleaded not guilty to
sex-related charges there and in
Minnesota it was interesting to hear
from his attorneys that he was surprised
by the verdict in this case because
everybody watching it thought maybe this
will be the time and it goes back like
we said to the 90s when you think about
the Rumblings and what we thought were
somewhat rumors to the many lawsuits
that he settled to this moment that
we're in right now so for people like
Lizette as you just heard they feel
Vindicated these are persistent
accusations and now there's Justice for
some yeah with the jury you never know
though thank you jerika